να το πω αγλικά σκάιςδλίμετς που λένκαι οι κυνέζει νομίζω ότι θα συνεχίσουμε με το
ίδιο τρόπο και αν μας δοθούν και κείνητρα τα ποία χω να φέρει προηγουμένος πιστεύω
γενικά ότι οι κύπρος με τις εξαωίες θα δ περισότερο καό ισοσπροσπαθήσετε σης σαν να
ς πιτηχημένως επιχισματίας από τους παλαιότερους σε αυτό που γάνετει στην κύπρο ισοσζητήσετε να έχετε
κάποιες συνάντινησεσις ώστε να δωθούν αυτά τα κίνητρα και να προχωρήγια την ώρα έχουν γίνει
ορισμένες επαφές ανθρώπους δικούς μου και τελικά ίσως να το κάνουν και ο ίδιος όταν
τα πράγματα φθάσουν σε κάποιο σημείο δηλαδή όταν πράξει μιαανταπόκριση από τη κυβέρληση τότε θαπεμο
θέλετει τώρα ότι ήδεν υπάρχε τώρα είναι όλα υποσκέψει και να και μπορεί και δεν
έχουμε λεφτά και λοιπ μάλιστεευχαριστώ παράπολλο πραγματικά τα όσα κάνακάνετε είναι ιδιαίτερα τόσο στην τέχνι
όσο και στη φαρμακοβίο μηχανία ευχαριστώ πάρα πολύ κυρεπιης ευχαριστώ για αυτή την ομορφη στης
ζήηση ευχαριστώ πυ αποδεκτι κατεέναστε σήμερα μαζί μας αφού δεν μιλάτε συχνώ πως ίπμενα στκά
μια κάποτε να στε καλά ευχαριστό πολύκαριστόθησ φίλες και φίλι αλλο ένανταένα λεύπο κασε ευταιστο
τέλος του τα λέμε την ερχόμενη ευδόματα